a BLM activist a co-founder of a BLM
chapter is endorsing Donald Trump we've
been used and abused for so long that
party they don't value our vote uh their
policies are basically um racist
policies and I believe it's a racist
party Donald Trump is he's the opposite
he's he's gonna tell you how it is he's
gonna give it to you straight Trump has
done more for the black community than I
can any president I can think of in my
lifetime all the brothers for some
reason right now are turning Tides right
now and I I just wonder what is the big
reason I think personally it's the
duplicity of the
Democrats the hypocrisy um we're not
stupid the brothers are not stupid we we
understand when someone's for us and
when someone is not I hope this is the
case I I hope this happens I'm not
holding my breath for it because I've
heard this just about every single
election cycle of my lifetime